so just a little bit about myself I'm a
senior security consultant at synopsis
we used to be with digital but we got
acquired by synopsis and I've been there
for about four years
I'm also the angular one of the angular
San Francisco organizers where we do
monthly meetups around JavaScript
typescript and specifically angular and
I also did a degree in ethical hacking
where I founded the leads ethical
hacking Society and the reason why I'm
talking to you today is because I'm a
JavaScript enthusiast
I love JavaScript I'm sure a few people
in the room also agree with that but a
lot of people tend to hate JavaScript
but I am NOT one of those people so what
is the OWASP top ten most of you know
what the OWASP top 10 is but the OWASP
top 10 is a powerful awareness document
for web application security and the
OWASP top 10 represents a broad
consensus about what most critical
application flaws are and that exists in
web applications so the reason why
there's multiple colors is because the
items in green are data-driven the items
in orange our community chosen and the
items in red are either substantially
new or changed since the most 2013
version so what I intend to do today is
try and cover as much as I can in 30
minutes on the OWASP top 10 and how it
relates to JavaScript and I can't cover
it all but there is an extended slide
deck online after this presentation with
lots more demos that you can go through
at your own leisure
so let's talk about a one injection fast
the dangers of mixing data and code so
the main issue that is caused through
injection is when we mix data and code
where user input is treated part of the
code context itself there are many types
of injection attacks so there's like
sequel injection no sequel injection log
injection and also command injection but
there's the list goes on and I don't
want to bore you to death because most
of you know the different kind of
injection attacks that exist in common
applications but let's take a look at
two that you might see when you're
looking at an JavaScript or node
applications in general
so the first thing that I want to talk
about is no sequel injection and the
official [ __ ] documentation that it's
not vulnerable to the traditional sequel
injection attacks because objects are
represented in theis on query or B some
queries are represented in beasts on
objects and most it might not be
vulnerable to traditional sequel
injection it's still vulnerable to
injection attacks if user input is
directly included in a collection method
so one example of this might be that you
have a find one method collection method
and you're trying to retrieve a user
from the database and this can be abused
if you can include a [ __ ] query
selector such as Dollar and E which is
short for not equals to if you can
include that or dollar GT to something
that's greater than you can use this to
abuse and login to the application so
let's just take a quick look at a
MongoDB example so we have this find one
collection while its collection with a
fine one query and this is coming from
user input because we have the request
user request query dot user and
passwords but the injection here would
be if you included a and dollar an e on
the password field because what this
actually would do is convert the query
output to basically say that the
password is not equal to an empty string
so you want to make sure that you're
trying to prevent this in general and of
course under the hood this would check
to see if it's an empty string and 99%
of the time the password isn't going to
be an empty string it's going to be a
hash password or clear text password
hopefully not so let's just take a look
at how that might actually work in
practice so we have a simple login host
and routes where we have this
authenticate function this authenticate
function takes in the body and it takes
in the user and the password so from the
body parameter and then it takes it into
the authentication and it tries to it
goes to connect to the MongoDB instance
so this time it's localhost and then we
have that simple collection now
obviously this would be vulnerable for
various different collections but in
this case we're going to talk about five
one so this is just trying to find one
user make
matches and obviously under the hood
this may do some other things but for
all intents purposes this is a very
simple application so obviously this can
be bypassed with it which I mentioned
with the username of admin this could
also just be greater than and then the
password would be greater than and it
will return back the entire collection
as we can see here we have the fine one
with the user and password so if we
include that password with the dollar GT
and we go to the application which I
only login with a fake password first
obviously you should never do this in
clear-text but anyway so as we saw if we
intercept that request and send that
again to the server and we do fake
password again once we capture that
request we can now delete the fake
password and just include the dollar GT
so this will allow us to because the
password is greater than and whatever
was supplied which is nante straitened
this is going to allow us to login to
the application so the simplest way to
prevent [ __ ] injection is to ensure
obviously and the safest way is to
basically ensure what you're expecting
is either a part string so it's directly
used in the global string object
directly or you can perform custom data
validation so one popular library and
from happy and is joy and you can define
custom info validation on on particular
on particular either user inputs or on a
scheme so you can do this by defining
with like it must be a string and must
be required it must be over type and you
know between 30 and 50 characters you
know whatever you want to do you can do
that with joy so even sequel injection
exists in node applications today we
cannot escape that relational databases
are here to stay they're gonna be around
for a long time so as you can see Drake
is not very happy when we dynamically
include the object user through string
concatenation and parvis as part of a
query string but Drake is very happy
when we're using parameterised queries
to ensure user input
safe so let's get back to some serious
content as enough Drake what we when we
think about an info prevention we want
to make sure that we're doing first
input validation and we want to try and
do data normalization so that input
validation is actually sane and it can
be probably validated but then we may
also want to consider when we're dealing
with XML files or various different
files performing something like output
encoding because as Philip to recap
anyone went to his presentation input
validation cannot be used as a
standalone protection it has to be
conjoined with something else such as
output encoding and then we're working
when we're working with databases you
might want to consider parameterised
queries or safe api's such as stored
procedures because you know stored
procedures don't always save you from
sequel sequel injection but if you're
doing it correctly and you generally are
okay so now we're going to move on to
broken authentication so one of my
colleagues I'm inverse Ankur reviewed an
Internet of Things application in China
while he was on site and it was built
with node and it was using the Express
framework and they wanted to preserve
memory space space on the device by not
writing not using custom middleware or
an authentication like passport they
wanted to write their own because it
would be cheaper so what you can see
here and obviously this is vulnerable to
node but it also could be vulnerable to
the client-side too but it would be less
impactful but what we have here is a
simple and object called sessions and
then we have this must be authenticated
middleware which takes in a request
response and next and then we take a
look at the cookie and that cookie is
basically assigned to the token and then
we check to see if that session token'
and exists in in the in the in the
session object and if it does exist then
we'll go to the next otherwise it will
say not authorized now this looks like
it could be okay but if anyone's looked
at javascript for a long time or enough
they're going to take a look at this
comparison table and see some weird
wonky things so let's just say that the
session object contained look at the
authentication session
it was checking against that value but
if you had an input validation string
which said import which was an invalid
string or pen against that session
object it's going to return false which
makes sense because if it's not there it
shouldn't return true the same for if
was what all that was supplied was an
empty cookie and that would obviously
return false as well but then we get to
some weird and interesting concepts
where if you have the session which is
constructor it's going to return to true
and the same for has own property which
is going to return to true now the
interesting thing here is because when
you create a JavaScript object
it essentially descends the base objects
so by default you have these values such
as underscore underscore proto which can
be used for various dangerous things
like prototype pollution I which I don't
cover today but I'm sure someone in the
audience probably will looking at you
there's also a constructor and has own
property and is prototype off so what we
saw before is basically saying the same
thing as if it does the sessions
constructor equal to sessions but
constructor and now of course is going
to be true so the exploit here would be
fairly trivial all we would do is
basically do a car request and include a
cookie which says token equals two
constructor or alternatively you could
just go into the browser and open the
developer tools add-in and the document
dot cookie and assign it to the token
constructor so let's take a look at
another example
if I can sort of lost the mouse okay
okay no yep okay so let's just replay
this the replay
nope let me just kill it and try again
okay
so play okay so let's just say we have
the simple Express application and as
you can see with using the cookie parser
to be able to retrieve the cookie we
have that sessions object which is empty
and we have that must be authenticated
middleware so what we're having now is
obviously we take the request cookies we
assign that to the token which then is
obviously checked to see if it exists
and if the session token contains that
value and if it does go next otherwise
say not authorized and then obviously
we're appending that as middleware so
before it even makes it to the get route
it's going to check that and as you can
see when we refresh the page it says not
authenticated but all we're gonna do is
go into the developer console define the
document cookie assign that token
constructor and then refresh the page
and as you can see now it says we're
authenticated and then i zoom in for
dramatic effect so obviously this is
quite bad and this definitely shouldn't
have happened but it's an unfortunate
consequence so how do we correctly
correctly check this and whilst I would
never recommend you write your own
authentication unfortunately sometimes
it's a necessity so I would highly
recommend looking into using the crypto
library which has timing safe equal
because when you're doing things like
sensitive password comparisons and
various other things if you have a
double equals or triple equals this is
vulnerable to timing attacks so you
should never do that anyway the next
thing is of course it performs a safe
comparison so it's not going to chase
it's not going to check the base object
it's only going to check the input
string and then you can also just do
this very happily it's not hacking
actually it's a relatively okay solution
but you can use the object or hazard
property or the if you're using Maps the
s6 Maps you can use dot hands oh I
repeated the thing anyway that was meant
to be the house so basically these do
not check the base property so these are
safe to use
in this context okay so now let's move
on to xxe so we all know that an extra
XML external entities xxe injection is
very common in pretty much all languages
that we see and note in this context is
no different if we want a quick recap
everyone knows what XML injection is but
we have XML the XML standard includes
the idea of external external general
past entities an external entity and in
during the parsing process the XML
document the parser will expand these
links and include the content of the URI
in the returned return document and a
common attack is basically to include
like a DTD so a document type definition
where you include some entities you can
do whatever other malicious things like
try and do denial of service through a
billion laughs attack you can do trying
to access internal resources and various
other you know means like trying to do
port scanning on your internal host and
node is no different it has a lot of XML
parsing libraries
I had an arguable someone told me that
no one uses them no to XML but I mean
I'd beg to differ when there's 80 48
thousand weekly downloads and 47,000
weekly downloads so no tax but a note
expert is actually in particularly
vulnerable Doug by design you can it's
long if user input is being entered into
this into this past function it's
actually vulnerable by design and you
can't do anything about it you would
have to do extra layers of security on
top of that to make it safe
there's also Lib XML jus and that live
xml j s is vulnerable if no ant is set
to true and this means no entities which
doesn't really make sense from a
configuration perspective maybe there
should be entities set to true rather
than no entities but that thing that's a
generic java or previous standard that
was set in the old implementations
because this is like a port of them
other implementation libraries so let's
just take a look at an the DB na which
is damn vulnerable node application this
has been created years ago to
demonstrate some particular issues so as
you can see here we
the requests stop files and basically
it's taking in some data and obviously
the mime tight is set set to text XML
and it's going into the parse XML string
that would be saved by default but
unfortunately we have this no end set to
true which means you would be able to
achieve XML injection in this context
you could have retrieved local local
instances from the files you could do
denial of service you could attack the
web server or whatever you wanted
because the source here is obviously the
request stop files going into parse XML
and then the misc configuration and the
sink here is the no end to true so how
would you try and prevent this in node
in general you may want to consider just
using a library that doesn't pass DT DS
so there's Sachs j s and sites j s
doesn't even process entities you can
configure it in a way where you can do
that but by default it's technically a
safe implementation and when you want to
use safe libraries definitely consider
using lib XML JSON ode expert because it
is safe by default but you have to make
that configuration change to make it
vulnerable and then if there are
contexts where you need like the
ampersand or greater than converted into
actual attributes you may want to
consider using lodash or underscore or m
he to basically do an escape functions
on you know technically on HTML but you
know in this context XML and of course
if you can't really approach those
things you want to make sure you're
doing strict input validation and output
encoding before actually passing the
data okay so let's talk about brokering
access control for a second
so we now live in a world where most of
the routing is done on the client side
and the client and server trust
boundaries are started to meld together
you know we have many client-side
frameworks and libraries now that offer
some kind of authorization but this
intended purpose from the client side is
purely only for aesthetics it's not
meant to be used for security so but the
sad truth is this is often neglected
when we look at many
occasions now from your source code
review or from the penetration test we
tend to see that these server and client
side boundaries have melded together and
you're all they're doing is doing
client-side controls to protect
themselves against an elevated privilege
so when you are working with an ojs
there are some things you can consider
for the server side so first you want
may want to use like node Casman for an
authorization and so the node node has
been allows you to write access control
lists allows you to write rollbase
role-based access controls and attribute
based access control you may want to
move this over to a framework to do all
the hard hard and heavy lifting for you
so sales j/s allows you to easily write
policies that might be good to make sure
that a person is of a type admin it's
very easy to do this inside chip sales
j/s and then finally you may want to
write some custom middleware so custom
middleware is very important when you're
working with things i JWT or JSON web
tokens or jobs however you want to call
it and you can do this at various
different levels you can do this at the
actual route level so as you can see in
this example we're doing like Earth
requires role admin you would obviously
you know verify the JWT then check
against that or you could do it if you
wanted to make sure someone was
authenticated first you may do it at the
pre route level so before it even
reaches these routes or you may want to
do some things afterwards at the after
route it's entirely up to you how you
want it deploy that but these are just
some potential solutions you might be
able to deploy in your organization so
just to give a quick angular example and
I'd highly recommend taking a look at
the second link here but angular has
some built in client-side validation
checks which can be used to load
resources or show in hide States you
have things like can activate can
activate child can deactivate can load
resolve and so on and obviously this is
nice from a user experience and what
should be shown to it to a user but
obviously these things can easily be
trivially bypassed and only you know
maybe if they're doing on this
then rendering the data it might be okay
but most of the time single page
applications throw everything to the
client and then depending on the you
know the JSON responses they receive
what data they have that is how its
represented on the on the client side
but the one interesting thing about
angular as well I'm not picking on
angular because it's bad it's actually a
super great framework but you can
basically use it's super powerful energy
probe and that's what the second
argument the second blog post talks
about is how you can use energy probe to
probe the client side and you can do
this basically to take a look at its
components and if they had like a
authentication component or an admin
component you could then basically start
to manipulate the changes and in in that
aspect so now I'm moving on to security
Mis configuration so nodejs
and most of the frameworks that are
built on top of nodejs return verbose
error messages as you can see from the
top example if the default value is set
so if you tend to see like you know a
fire that's not found or a certain error
came back you would want to make sure
that this is set properly and then you
can do this by defining the production
mode and with the node environment you
can also actually set this up as a
middle as a middleware so you can kind
of consider this at you know are all
routes you want to make sure this
middleware is set so before anything
runs it's set to production with a node
environment so that technically would
save you from if your client if your
actual server implementation changes or
it gets deployed to a new server and the
node environment changes so you can do
this at the middleware layer and of
course we all know about am the
dangerous of running as root for any
Linux application running as you know
running with sudo has a greater chance
of modifying the underlying operating
system if they have like a command
injection for example they could
obviously just do RTFM forward slash but
there are some things that you may want
to consider so for example and
you know go through you may want to go
through the default run scripts to make
sure they're not running with sudo
that's the first thing you can do and
the second thing you can do is sudo is
required after the port is bound you can
essentially then you know call process
and set the GID a new ID so these are
some things you can consider in nodejs
so let's move on to my most arguably
strongest topic and I have a lot of
things to say about cross-site scripting
okay so XSS is super easy to introduce
and I think koto and Mike's talk talked
about the same things I'm about to talk
about now but as we all know Dom Christ
cites Dom Dom XSS generally occurs when
you know inputs injection sinks in the
Dom or other browser API is a called
we've used as a controlled input so as
you can see here we have a source such
as location dot hash and then it's being
assigned to the inner HTML which says
welcome username or is being appended in
this case and of course and of course
the script execution context here would
be just to include the username and that
should be a hash not a not a not a
parameter but obviously if you had a
hash here this would allow for the
execution so and Dom XSS in today's
ecosystem is super difficult to find
you'll notice the most static code
analysis tools cannot identify XSS it's
it's pretty paramount that it's so
difficult and obviously when you're
defining variables in a way if you take
a look at these hacker 1 reports and you
take a look at the code you're gonna go
where is the dhamma success but it is
actually quite difficult to identify and
browsers actually tend to pass and
render HTML differently so the Dom
specification for each browser while
there are standards they're not always
conforming to those standards and they
implement things a little differently so
there's a good explanation from live
overflow where he goes into a lot of
detail about the Google XSS but then he
also goes into detail about why is this
thing rendered
this way on firefox or why is this way
rendering on chrome and there's some
wonderful examples on Charlotte Shizuko
at UK which is basically a fuzzing
website for browsers and insert script
known as Alex and also gareth Hayes have
some wonderful examples on there about
how you can get quirks like there was
like things trying to remove a greater
than character to bring an entire string
together and various different contexts
and of course the dangers of the Dom as
well or browsers in general is that
there's so many execution contexts
there's wonderful resources like html5
set org that you can take those payloads
and basically use them inside your
security unit tests minutes okay and of
course and there's also character sets
so browsers come with various different
character sets like utf-8 utf-16 pleura
six was crazy and just threw a ton of
character sets in there at some point so
there's tons of different and ways to
basically get JavaScript execution even
when it doesn't look like JavaScript
execution and then you also have script
gadgets where it's basically taking HTML
injection and being processed in their
way where it's executed by JavaScript so
it highly recommend taking a look over
look at all these resources and then
you'll kind of get to the point why you
understand things are so difficult so we
have 5 minutes and 20 slides let's let's
do it
so frameworks like angular react in view
definitely reduce the attack surface but
I'm not going to go through all of these
but essentially there are pundants of
ways that you can introduce XSS by
basically using frameworks in a way
which are either being abused and
various different aspects so the first
example would be to combine templating
engines with third-party libraries and
frameworks so in angularjs if you
included jquery dot text which in
general websites that's actually a safe
way to insert HTML but with jquery dot
text angular would actually render curly
braces as part of the angular
expressions so you technically get XSS
you could obviously do all the others as
well one interesting one is element ref
because it allows you to access
dumb so you get in a HT amount so I'm
not going to click that so basically I'm
gonna ignore this video you can watch it
online with through the video and but
base owner explained okay so as you can
see here we get remote code execution
and it's quite strange why and this is
because one line of code in the signal
application basically was using danger
to set in HTML and this allowed you to
essentially get various different
execution contexts on the client side or
sorry in the mobile applications
it was XSS on electron it was a remote
code execution
so the general prevention techniques is
quite critical here and you know there's
various different ways to achieve this
so you can use templating engines such
as mustache or pork or ejs and they do
HTML contextual encoding you can use
angular react or view to ensure that and
you're making sure they're using their
sanitization functions by design and of
course their secure filters you want to
make sure that you're doing Dom purify
or doing client-side sanitization
because whilst it's good on the server
once you can render it in the browser
you can make a better safe assumption
that it is secure or it is sanitized
properly and of course if you can use
that in a text or in code you are in the
correct context and that is quite
important so I'm gonna skip this very
this next topic very quickly but you
should definitely look at
defense-in-depth strategies so you want
to try and deploy CSP and take a look
obviously Cotto and Mike just talked
about trusted types but I would highly
recommend looking at these as extra
layers of security on top of your
applications okay
so two minutes left and this is the most
important part everyone so I'm gonna go
over time sorry so this is the most
important thing when it comes to I guess
the node ecosystem and it's using
components with known vulnerabilities so
it's very important to carefully audit
third pipe code and obviously doing
source code review is very critical in
this aspect but if you take a look at an
F
package lists or any kind of
package.json you're gonna see a
thousands of different kind of packages
in there and it's not going to be
feasible to do source code of view but
if you do find an issue in an NPM
package you can now use the new github
feature where you can directly report
that issue to the project itself in a
safe way and of course if you want to
implement and auditing tools in your CI
CD pipeline you can use NPM order yarn
order audit j/s retire j/s and snick
tests so you can use these in different
contexts you would use snick if you're
using open source node you could use
retire j/s if you're looking at
client-side JavaScript you could use
bower for client client side and package
manager yarn with yarn audit fix which
basically wraps over NPM and then also
NPM audit fix so these are some simple
examples and what you see here is that
obviously things like next is next yes
is super important in the react world
but in two cases it was vulnerable to
arbitrary read through directory
traversal it was also vulnerable to an X
access which obviously is quite bad
because react adds adds a lot of
properties but if you build on top of
that you essentially are seeing a lot of
problematic areas so it's super
important to do dependency checking on
node modules so I saw someone was taking
a screenshot so feel free to finish that
okay so our mitigation techniques so
this is probably the most important part
that you might want to consider this is
my last slide actually so you want to
make sure that you track outdated
libraries and components for using snick
or retire j/s or yarn or Bower and so on
and you want to try and maintain a
technology list asset registry list or
in some way but there was an interesting
talk from loco moco sec that basically
talks about you know code province and
application security in applications and
what they tend to do is only do a subset
of those and dependencies because if you
go too far down the chain there's less
likely of a code sink actually happening
from user input but then you can build a
technology list through things like the
CL is so you can use it for NPM there's
little s for yarn there's yarn Alice and
why and then of course says Bower Bower
list as well and one thing that I also
might want to recommend for you to do
but it's obviously up to your
interpretation has basically pin your
dependency versions where possible
because there was obviously an
interesting scenario with event stream
an event stream allow obviously was
affected a lot of organizations but if
you can pin your dependencies to
something that you want knew was safe
and include that in the package when
other developers install it by using NPM
shrink wrap or yarn lock they're going
to use this exact same dependency
version that you were using and
therefore it may actually save them for
being compromised so that was everything
that I had the online version is at the
bottom there's the 30 minute version and
the hour version with multiple demos
there so feel free to go ahead and take
a look at it and if you have any
questions I'll be around so thank you